hallo mein name ist ja ist mein name
schreibt sie in die kommentare
ihr seht schon im titel einige blätter
meine damen und herren wir machen heute
mal wieder 1 beziehungsweise einen
testen und zwar auf facebook ihr seht
hier gerade nicht dass es facebook ist
aber es ist facebook august joas wir
schauen heute wie gut meine augen sind
zwar angeblich fehlen dort 91 prozent
also mal schauen
hier klicken jetzt einfach mal auf play
und sehen schon ein gutes jahr eiszeit
test jetzt sollte das ganze größe noch
mal losgehen some people can seymour
carlos denn was ich dachte dass nur
einige leute weniger bin nicht dumm wenn
einige leute mehr farben winkel es ist
ja klar dass andere leute weniger sehen
können ja tut mir leid an der stelle
würde ich sagen dass ich mich dann auch
mal das was jetzt hier kombi oder das
was jetzt hier von yahoo
also bin ich einer von diesen leuten
weniger sehen dieser test hat vier teile
stage 1 easy dann medienexpertin
professional also steigert sich von dem
schwierigkeitsgrad her statewatch auch
die 19 auf people can take ms
es gibt noch ein paar leute die einfach
kein englisch wenn die beispielsweise
der quiz hersteller hier stimmt also ich
sagen wir gerade das nur neun prozent
aller teilnehmer dieses kurses wirklich
die letzte phase bestehen können
also ich meine ich kann gut sehen
eigentlich deswegen mal schauen
jetzt geht es hier los mit stage 1 meine
damen und herren ich sagt übrigens auch
immer meine damen und herren
fühlt ihr euch dann halt wenn ich das
sage oder soll ich euch lucio nennen
ja vielleicht sollte ja mal anfangen da
wird er zu fünf eingeblendet und hier 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 also 54 32 was soll
ich machen
egal was ist meine aufgabe also das was
ich hier gerade sie ist dass die neuen
andere farbe hat also mal abwarten
die neuen ja also wer das nicht gesehen
hat ja da hinten ist die tür wurde
dieses quiz einfach auf meiner facebook
feeds startseite angezeigt und ich habe
mir gedacht okay ich muss das machen ich
habe heute noch keine richtige video.de
aber ich würde sagen wir machen einfach
weiter
das ist jetzt auf jeden fall die neuen
gewesen 54 die 2 wenn dass sich die zwei
ist schließlich mein youtube-kanal ja
die 23
aber ein paar sekunden später ich bin
der aus dem haus schau dort an meinem
arm
sorry dass ich dich verständigt haben
aus dem flur aber im fluss bester
telefonen fantasieren verdammt ernst das
ist die vier diesmal kommt schon okay
aber das ist auch noch stage 1 und es
wird wirklich gesagt das stage viel dass
da nur neun prozent durch kommen hier
jetzt noch mal ein bild das 6
bisher ist ultra sie aber bleibt mal
dran bleibt dran und last song like da
man merkt wieder dass ich kein stativ
stage 2 ist jetzt mittlerweile
angebrochen meine damen und herren also
m die 9
es ist die 9 hey wir brauchen wir nichts
sagen jetzt kommen hier kommt da die
neuen nächste sache also ich würde grob
sagen die 7
aber das ist gerade schon schwierig also
ich leg mich einfach auf die sieben
jetzt hier fest die wird schon noch ein
bisschen anders aussieht so ein bisschen
mehr gras für mich ja die sieben war es
jetzt auch um dem fall aber freue ich
muss ganz ehrlich mal ganz kurz anmerken
der test ist gut wenn man sehen will ok
kann ich farben auseinander halten aber
ich meine beisammen beispiel das hat
auch voll viel mit der belichtung des
raumes und keine ahnung was zu tun bei
mir hier zum beispiel gerade ist es
relativ hell es sind gerade 33 grad raus
deswegen ist mein kopf auch ein bisschen
macho aber ich will mich nicht
beschweren
wir versuchen das heute zu reist weiter
geht das ist definitiv die drei das
sieht man schon oder
doch ich würde sagen die drei nächster
test 54 ich glaube das ist die 5 diesmal
das ist ein bisschen mehr so ein ping
das andere ist ein bisschen mehr sein
lila ton jahre sehen wir schon die 5 war
diesmal auch richtig stage 3 haben wir
jetzt schon erreicht meine lieben damen
und herren lk i look to you das hier
müsste glaube ich die vier sein sobald
ich das jetzt irgendwie richtig
beurteilen kann wir sehen schon das geht
runter ja genau die vier was diesmal
aber man sieht schon die farben liegen
sehr sehr nah beieinander hier also das
wird schon krass schwieriger von mal zu
mal ich hab euch übrigens den tester
oder beschreibung verlinkt falls ihr den
auch mal machen wollte und wenn ihr den
test macht dann schreibt über euer
ergebnis in die kommentare also weiter
gekommen seid und jetzt schreibt
wahrscheinlich eh wieder jedoch das hat
40 bin ich 40 gekommen alles klar
3 ich würde sagen es ist die 4 da sieht
man nämlich noch einen kleinen
unterschied immer dabei und jetzt in die
täter weg genau die vier war diesmal
auch richtig hier zählt wieder runter
diesmal ist es glaube ich die acht alles
andere ist ein bisschen schwarz die acht
ist so ein bisschen dunkelblau genau da
haben wir die acht die hier richtig
angezeigt wurde die frage ist genau
jetzt kommt noch mal eins hier was ich
weiß dass ich gerade pausiert habe aber
er hört mir nicht sagen dass sie
irgendwas ein anderer ton ist 2000 jahre
später
nein das ist alles gleich also es wird
gesagt dass nur neun prozent diesen
komplette test richtig machen und ich
glaube ich versage jetzt sogar schon
beim letzten rätsel vom stage 3 ich lass
das jetzt mal kurz die so ein geländer
die schneide jetzt mal eben gerade nicht
dass wir viele ab dass ich bei solchen
tests immer so zwischendurch schneide
aber ich meine schaut euch das jetzt mal
an und sagten wir ob ihr da irgendwie
irgendwo eine andere farbe mein gott ich
mache jetzt einfach auf weiter ich sag
jetzt mal die drei also ich müsste jetzt
wirklich raten und es ist die 1 warte
mal okay wenn man es weiß dann sieht man
schon dass die einst anders ist nie
freunde das war's jetzt hier von diesem
test den ich gerade gemacht habe weil
man muss wirklich auch sagen dass ein
paar sachen echt hart beschissen waren
also gerade am ende habe ich gar keinen
unterschied mehr kann trotzdem eine sehr
verehrte lux wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich sehr über
einen darum hochfahren schreibt eure
ergebnis unten die kommentare und jetzt
wo wir das wasser ziel vom bio das war
es jetzt hier vom bio
hier können jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
aus schenkungen jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und managen abonnent zeit
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]